soll ich wieder etwas gesünderes machen
oder mcdonald ofenkartoffeln mit scream
käse und salat bestellt was die da von
willkommen bei myvideo die arbeit schaut
natürlich euch gehts wundert euch nicht
über die müllsäcke das alles fand
flaschen die wir heute eigentlich mal
weggehen sollen ja heute ich hab gerade
gefrühstückt wir haben schon etwas
später um genau zu sein 12 uhr
ich muss jetzt allerdings gleich zu
umgehen und ich war halt ein bisschen
auf youtube unterwegs und hab gesehen
sehr viele machen gerade dieses
instagram bestimmt ein tag mein leben
ich finde das irgendwie ziemlich
interessant ich habe da hat übrigens
sehr lecker cornflakes gegessen und den
kaffee habe ich immer noch nicht
ausgetrunken
ich möchte auch reden wir nicht und
dabei ist mir die wundervolle idee
gekommen
mach doch nicht einen tag bestimmt
instagram dein leben sondern einen tag
bestimmt instagram deine ernährung ich
bin echt mal gespannt wie ihr so darauf
reagiert für euch er dafür entscheidet
dass ich mich gesund ernähre
oder halt ungesund keine ahnung weil
eigentlich war es ja vorbildlich von
euch wenn ihr immer für die gesündere
variante abstimmen würde das heißt ich
poste den ganzen tag auf instagram immer
so zwei auswahlmöglichkeiten einmal eine
richtig gesunde und einmal eine eher
ungesunde variante falls ich mir auch
sollte man nicht folgt ganz wichtig ist
kurz eingeblendet macht es auf jeden
fall vielleicht kann man das ja
irgendwann auch mal mit anderen sachen
machen und ja ich würde sagen der ladung
gar nicht lange ich muss mir gesagt
jetzt jeden moment zur uni und muss
natürlich was zu trinken mitnehmen
deswegen hab ich mir gedacht ich brauche
ja das was meine story und zwar habe ich
das gerade in meiner station angekündigt
30 prozent finden das cool zehn prozent
für uns umbringen
ja ich habe jetzt zwei stellen uni und
ich poste jetzt einfach mal in die story
ob ich besser pepsi mitnehmen soll oder
natürliches mineralwasser ich bin echt
gespannt ich würde das machen wir mal
später kommt natürlich auch nochmal zeit
hinzu wir sehen was ich heute alles zu
essen werde
und ja wir sehen uns bis leicht so und
zwar muss ich jetzt zur uni soll ich
pepsi mitnehmen oder wasser ich habe nur
zwei stunden deswegen reicht das so
leute das ist jetzt in meiner stories
wir warten jetzt einfach mal kurz aber
ich musste hier schon um 10 uhr in
sachen
und ist inzwischen so leute ich hab ich
jetzt fertiggemacht
mein handy habe ich irgendwie vergessen
jetzt gucken wir mal ich bin echt
gespannt 414 für pepsi 7 50 prozent
wasser es finde ich ja cool also
wirklich ihr denkt anscheinend an die
gute ernährung der skoda lange schnell
gedanken schreiben und wasser nehmen wir
mit
bis später also leute los geht's ja ich
bin wirklich auch mal gespannt wenn es
halt später am essen geht ob er dann
auch sagt alex gesund ernährt oder ob
die mehrheit für was anderes ist als ich
gehe jetzt erstmal ein bisschen lernen
dann melde ich mich später
bis gleich ich bin fertig und es war
brutal langweilig und hier ist es voll
dunkelfeld euro das waren auch richtig
unvorbereitet die kamera stand die ganze
zeit auf dem dach so leute haben jetzt
zwei stunden später und ich habe echt
hunger deswegen muss sich jetzt schnell
manchmal hängen was ist denn zu essen
gibt so leute also ich hab jetzt
gepostet was soll ich machen selber
machen lieferservice was soll ich machen
selber machen ja das kann man auch
besser ausdrücken aber ich hoffe jeder
weiß was gemeint ist jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt ob wir wieder sagt alex gesund
selber machen oder lieferservice
ich hatte schon mehr bergauf
lieferservice ich bin gespannt wir
fahren jetzt erst mal zurück bis gleich
so leute
es geht ja soll ich bin jetzt zu hause
ist auch mal da dann habe ich gestern
extra meine kollegen haben wir heute um
10 und zurückgehen wollte man bis 1000
kommen vom 1 ich habe immer gesagt dass
meine lebens nicht so leute jetzt muss
ich mal kurz gucken wir was ihr euch
entschieden habt also ich war ja
eigentlich bin lieferservice scheiße 5
prozent selber machen
45 potenziellen lieferservice hamas mit
ja leute das heißt selber machen und ich
stimme jetzt noch kurz ab auf instagram
ob ich für juli mit kochen soll oder
nicht
so leute ich bin jetzt wieder zu hause
und jetzt glaube ich abgestimmt für
selber machen und ich wollte noch kurz
frage soll ich für juli mit kochen oder
nicht und so leute ich muss mal kurz die
kamera lagen in der zeit gehe ich
einkaufen weil ich muss jetzt kochen ich
kann eigentlich gar nicht kochen aber
ich gebe mein bestes
wir sehen uns gleich wie ich muss heute
abend aufkochen
so leute ich bin wieder da hab auch
schon eingekauft ich habe auch schon das
essen fertig gemacht die kamera musste
erstmal ein bisschen laden deswegen habe
ich mich dann nicht mitgenommen und zwar
habe ich mich für ofenkartoffeln mit
sour cream käse und salat entschieden
und wenn man sich das mal anschaut finde
ich das sieht echt richtig lecker aus
problem ist nur ich wollte juli wirklich
aus mitmachen wir haben auch bei der
abstimmung im moment gehen der
abstimmung haben 59 prozent für ja
gestimmt also eigentlich hätte er etwas
bekommen
er mag keine rufen wir dort will das
wusste ich nicht deswegen also die halt
alleine also leute ich habe echt von den
appetit könnte glaube ich sehr sehr heiß
seien also die sonst vielleicht nicht
dass allah gesündeste der rest aber
schon also bis jetzt habe ich mich heute
echt richtig gesundheit gehabt das kann
ich sonst gar nicht so von mir sollte
ich vielleicht öfter mal machen deswegen
fällt mir auf jeden fall noch im salon
alex wie die einzel erst mal ruhe auf
und dann werde ich mich wieder und man
sehen was zum nachmittag dran ist wird
abend dann vielleicht noch nicht gleich
nachtisch du bist dann so leute wir
haben jetzt gerade nachmittag
allerdings also eigentlich schon abend
nur einen tagesrhythmus verschiebt sich
heute irgendwie ein bisschen da ich auch
erst um halb zwei uhr gefrühstückt habe
nach der uni und 15 uhr mittag gegessen
habt wir haben jetzt 18 uhr könnte ich
jetzt mal nachmittags so ein kuchen
essen oder gesund und so habe ich mir
einmal von starbucks kuchen geholt das
ist so schuh drücke kuchen oder so und
vom rewe hier ganz normal so trauben die
auch echt lecker sind und ich denke mal
wenn man sich diese beiden sachen wie so
anguckt er schließlich ganz von alleine
was das gesunde ist also ich bin
gespannt ich poste das jetzt mal meine
story einfach die teile kommen aus
indien ursprung indien und ich hätte es
eher spanien von nudeln eier
wir sehen uns das vielleicht so leute da
sich mein tagesrhythmus ein bisschen
verschoben hat auch schon vom
mittagessen ja bin ich jetzt erst beim
nachmittags essen also kaffee und kuchen
diese trauben essen oder diesen
starbucks puppen abstimmen so leute
jetzt übrigens schon zehn minuten um
also also ich bin eigentlich für kuchen
das recht cool und hatte das sah gut aus
55 muss den kuchen 45 prozent rauchen
insgesamt schon 700 stimmen ja das muss
nämlich mit und ich muss jetzt meinen
videos halten das gleich online kommt
ich schaff's gehen nicht mehr bis 19 uhr
aber ich denke also bis gleich so läuft
jetzt bin ich
er sieht vor lecker aus das ist wirklich
eine kalorienbombe
das war es dann auch mit der gesunde
ernährung heute alleine aus deutschland
viel schokolade also heute schon jetzt
schon ein video die sie dann später
wieder
wir haben 18 20 jetzt gerade das später
so leute wir haben jetzt ja hallo kannst
du das mal scharfstellen bitte wir haben
jetzt schon halb neun und ich habe
gerade in meine story gepostet wie sieht
es aus soll ich jetzt er wieder was
gesundes kochen oder da habe ich zum
ende so leute da ich mich heute
eigentlich schon ziemlich gesund ernährt
habt jetzt die frage zum abendessen soll
ich wieder etwas gesünderes machen oder
zu mcdonald stimmt jetzt ab
ich habe absoluten favoriten aber ich
bin mal gespannt haben einfach mal
wieder fünf minuten ab ich habe einen
ganz eindeutigen favoriten weil ich
eigentlich gerade überhaupt keinen bock
mehr
jetzt wieder im supermarkt zu rennen und
dann wieder irgendwas zu kaufen was ich
dann koche und dann in fünf stunden
gefühlt das zu essen weil ich hab hunger
also leute ich bin gespannt bis gleich
so leute wir schauen jetzt einfach mal
hier kurz rein fünf minuten sind um und
wir haben 63 prozent
macdonald bevor ich jetzt allerdings
zehn fahrer- und esse was ich möchte
habe ich mir gedacht nein das mache ich
nicht und zwar frage ich euch jetzt ob
ich ein mac menü ganz normale stellen
soll oder vegetarisch essen soll ja auch
mal was das machen wir noch schnell dann
geht's aber los
ja bis gleich soll ich einfach irgendein
mac mini meiner wahl essen oder solche
vegetarisch essen
ich bin gespannt abstimmen so leute ich
vereinslos ich guck mal kurz noch was
jetzt abgestimmt wurde ich glaube die
haben wir 70 prozent mitte 30 prozent
vegetarisch finde ich eigentlich schade
weil man muss ja nicht unbedingt mehr
fleisch essen aber es ist weder so leute
wir sind fertig
ich habe noch einen kleinen cheeseburger
hier immer noch hunger hat auf jeden
fall was man hunger hat auf jeden fall
ganz gut ich habe mich nur gefragt ob
ich mir noch ein eis holen also das habe
ich mich im unterbewusstsein gefragt
aber es muss auch nicht sein so ein ice
ist natürlich immer noch so ein
zusätzlicher schöner nachtisch nur sind
natürlich auch noch zusätzliche kalorien
deswegen frage ich euch jetzt auf
instagram dann würde ich aber auf jeden
fall durch den drei fahren die leute ich
bin gerade noch bei mcdonald und ich
habe gedacht ich komm hol sie dir noch
ein eis die im mac greif soll ich das
machen in maxflow wie stimmen ab ist das
erlaubt ja oder nein so leute fünf
minuten sind rum wir haben 86 prozent
für jahr 14 nein das heißt ich kaufe
doch nach ist kalt und ich pass doch
kriegsähnlich auf
[Musik]
viel aufmerksamkeit hallo ich hätte gern
ein mac flori mit smarties bitte
und dazu kommt noch eine mittlere pommes
habe ich jetzt auch noch dankeschön
übrigens für die ganzen tollen
abstimmung ich fand eigentlich jede
abstimmung richtig cool außerdem mittag
wo ich selber kochen sollte euer ernst
leute schreibt doch mal in die
kommentare welches macquarie ist dein
lieblings mac flori also mainz auf jeden
fall mit smarties nur mich regt es immer
richtig auf wenn die da keine smarties
rein tun aber hier sind viele smarties
der leute das war eigentlich jetzt schon
der ganze tag ich bin gespannt ob
irgendwas passiert sonst werde ich mich
erst morgen wieder ich wünsche euch eine
gute nacht und bis gleich so was geht ja
da wären wir schon am nächsten tag ich
bin gerade dabei das video zu schneiden
ich bin auch schon fast fertig außer das
ende das ist irgendwie jetzt gerade ist
eingefallen die traum hier aus indien
mal ganz ehrlich wenn ich wusste dass
wir uns in die un kommen
okay vielleicht auch nicht alle wir
machen war ein kurzes resümee ich habe
gestern angefangen wo das frühstück hat
noch keiner mit entschieden
das waren einfach cornflakes danach gab
es was da in der uniqa hat mir noch
offen kartoffel gemacht mit salat
danach hatte ich kuchen gegessen und
abends kam dann dann halt dazu also ich
bin in den tag gestartet und hat mir
gedacht worden die meist recht gut wird
dir du sollst dich richtig gesund
ernähren anscheinend zum ende hin wurde
sondern weil immer schlimmer trotzdem
war es ein cooler tag und es hat echt
spaß gemacht wenn ich so was soll man
machen soll dann schreibt gerne in die
kommentare mit was top kommentare lese
ich mir dann durch und vielleicht machen
wir das last auf jeden fall dann nach
oben dafür noch ein paar und wir sehen
uns morgen wieder morgen gibt es ein
neues video hat rein und nicht vergessen
schön gesund halte er nichts so auch zum
bäcker gehen auch mal live übertragen
auch irgendwie probieren wie immer gut